you don't know everything about me
the avengers weren't my first family
it's important for us to understand how
this family has shaped the person that
natasha became natasha don't slouch i'm
not slouching listen to your mouth oh my
god this is up all right enough all of
you i didn't say anything elena is the
kind of little sister character she's
there to get the job done and her
relationship with natasha then becomes
quite interesting because they're
constantly butting heads in the way that
siblings do why do you always do that
thing what thing the pose
it's a fighting pose you're a total
poser it's really fun to be able to see
those two characters when they're
together
such a [ __ ]
it's good to see you too sis
it was so wonderful to be able to do
this with florence because she's such a
wonderful actor feisty and fiery and
just full of life scarlett's been the
leading female face of these films for
10 years
that's definitely a cool badge to wear i
remember her daughter came to set one
day and i was like what does she think
you do and she goes oh you know fight
baddies for a living and i was like but
that is what you do
i like your best god i knew it i knew
you did it's so cool right
you